an inferno in what's known as Chile's
Garden City Strong Winds of up to 60 km
an hour and scorching Heat have been
feeding the Flames destroying everything
in their path especially
homes look there is nothing left of my
house nothing as you can see the
neighbor across the street could not
leave he burned to death because he did
not want to leave his house I lived
alone
here president Gabriel borich declared a
state of emergency in the valaro region
and address the nation to say that so
far dozens have
died given the conditions of this
tragedy the number of fatal victims will
surely increase in the coming hours but
the figures we are announcing are those
that have been confirmed by the
appropriate
authorities the fires come in the middle
of a heat wave and as tens of thousands
of Chileans have been heading to the
coastal region of valpariso for summer
holidays traffic jams on the main
Highway are hindering the mobility of
firefighters and
ambulances the government has declared a
curfew from 9:00 p.m. to 10 a.m. in the
region the curfew will help to free up
the roads for emergency vehicles but
also so that people who must be
evacuated can do so as quickly as
possible and so that no one can be left
wandering around the areas that have
been
evacuated the government is trying to
prevent looting thousand of people have
been forced to evacuate in just minutes
but some especially elderly people with
limited Mobility could not Escape in
time the government says it will
investigate arson as the cause of these
deadly fires but first says the
president the priority is to save lives
Lucia Newman Al jazer
Santiago make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer